hello good morning good afternoon good
evening good whatever the hell of where
you are in the world and welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
Matthew say hello hello
Paris say hello howdy howdy hey hey no
stormy today I'm afraid he is off
galavanting but hey we're here so let's
just get into it
[Music]
foreign
um it's not a Stargate full video today
so if you're watching expecting us to
talk about Stargate for an hour
We're Not Gonna but I do have a little
bit of an update about stuff we've been
talking about in the last uh couple of
weeks
um
good news bad news sort of situation but
it's on it's nothing major so we'll see
what's going on but we're also going to
talk about other things that we're
hoping for in 2023 so just first before
we get into it how you doing guys
pretty good
really good enjoying life let's go back
to work tomorrow
stupid work
Stargate Atlantis jumper this time I
wore it last week I I was gonna switch
it up this week but uh
what I was wearing so I went with it you
know
okay no longer available on
slidestruct.com because I took the side
track a bit out but a better version is
now available because you can actually
have the SGA gate yes as well I think on
scientist truck.com
um yeah
um but anyway
guys did you see the video I did
yesterday with our Dawn Ferrick
I did it's not even a Tracker and I
watched it exactly you had no freaking
clue we were talking about for 90
minutes I was watching it and I was like
yeah I have no idea what that is I don't
know what that is
I just heard the name Jeffrey Combs
talked about 70 times everyone is
Jeffrey Combs apparently he appears in
everything he's also appeared in
Stargate and he's also a pig oh god he's
a bit never if Jeffrey Combs is yeah he
plays everything so he um depending on
how you count it he either appeared in I
think it's 12 characters or about 18
characters or something because he plays
one character but it's a genetic
thing so he's like there's like he plays
the same character like five times but
anyway
we'll move on from that so a bit of a
start like how uh Cliff Simon played
about 15 15 different characters if you
count all the variations of ball on
Stargate
yes exactly
um I just the updates on Stargate and
then we can have a chat about that but
um I had a conversation with somebody
that works they don't work correctly for
Amazon but they work for a company who
does a lot of work with Amazon and MGM
and he was talking about that Amazon
apparently have had other conversations
you know so they put out
um a call pitch
um so you know like asking for companies
to pitch ideas for the Stargate series
and movie
[Music]
um
basically the update is that they've
gone back and actually apparently this
week spoke unto a couple of those other
companies so I know the guys who did the
boys was one unfortunately I know that
um Bad Robot was another there was
another company that I've never heard of
um but I think they did the man in the
High Castle if I remember right
um I did Google it at the time it was a
couple of days ago I'm sorry so I've um
sort of Forgotten but um and and a
couple of others
all I was told was that they've gone
back and had conversations with them
again or asking them to maybe
I don't want to say pitch again but it
just sounds a bit like they're not quite
sure where it's going with penguin and
Parker so they maybe are just opening
the door a little bit if any other
companies are still interested keeping
our options open it seems to me like
that all the way through this Amazon are
really really good at that
they seem to try to keep their options
open right up until they decide
I don't know if that's just a normal
thing within the industry but they do
that but it feels to me as you might
have more insight into this than me but
it feels to me like Amazon run
making movies and TV more like a
business than any of the other big
companies do
um
and you know who that is first and
foremost
Jeff Bezos yeah I mean that's that's the
only way he knows how to do it uh
which I think is successful for them in
a lot of ways but also it's it's it's
it's weird because he doesn't I guess
understand
I don't know if he truly understands
film and TV as a medium of themselves so
that's that might be why we're getting
the whole MGM plus thing and then we
have free V now we have uh Amazon Prime
as well who knows what's going to stay
on there or end up on their MGM plus uh
I think part of that is just him trying
to make big business moves because he
sees what zazlov's doing over at Warner
Brothers in Discovery and then uh he
sees what Disney did with jpak and Iger
prior to them kind of undoing all that
but uh I I think he kind of feels the
need to
do something epic but he's changing
epics to MGM I just had to add that
there yeah uh yeah I I think he's just
trying to stick strictly business I
don't know if he truly understands the
film medium and
it very well can and should be handled
like a business in a lot of ways yeah
yeah but there are other ways it really
shouldn't be because it is a very odd
medium you have to every TV show that
he's making gets grants from certain
States gets grants from certain
communities to film things in certain
areas I mean there's a lot of different
things that go through there's a lot of
Hoops and hurdles to go through just to
make a small TV show and he's not making
small TV shows so
now billions of dollars literally
you got any ideas do you have any
thoughts Matt
yeah
Harris is the one to talk about like The
Insider stuff in in television I'm I'm
just
everything he's just said for me is over
my head
well this is it seems to be a lot when I
when I look into other TV shows and
things and you know you think like why
did this person get that role like this
but all these like you want a young
actor comes through it always seems to
be that well actually their mom's a
staged director that did this in order
or that director his mom is blah blah
blah there all seems to be it's like not
what you know it's who you know with a
lot of studios and things yeah you know
when projects come up you know it's that
and it seems to be almost like it's not
family because it's still a business and
it's still a bit Cut Throat what have
you but there just seem to be like it's
what you two you know
Amazon doesn't seem to quite operate the
same way that and Alex I was talking to
the um person that kind of got to be so
careful on lives I spoke to another
person about this and I was asking them
is is that the way it feels with sort of
agents and Screen direct you know and
and people are casting directors and
people like this and they're saying yeah
that Amazon don't operate the same way
as other businesses they as other
Studios and things it's very much um
um
it's not if you come up with a pitch at
Amazon you better have some you better
answer questions about budget and things
because that's like they hit that really
early on whereas other companies
maybe don't
um that's a later conversation if that
makes sense whereas Amazon have an idea
about that sort of thing really early
and the other thing is that with Amazon
a lot of companies will announce they're
doing something Amazon don't announce
they're doing [ __ ] until it's basically
done
um they they announced Things Early
through and that I didn't realize that
really until the Henry Cavill thing
recently where he's announced Warhammer
they did I was told by three or four
different people they did not want to do
that
Amazon did not want to announce it yet
they were basically Henry Cavill made
them he basically said you know like no
I really really need you to do this
um and they didn't want it but they're
just they're just a weird cookie I don't
know if it's a good thing or not I can't
quite make my mind so they treat
everything at every pitch what like
another Studio front for example would
would take a pitch as this is an idea I
have for a television series let's see
what we can do with it but they'll
they'll look at it as more of a business
pitch this is the idea I've got and this
is how we can make money and this is the
budget I've got in mind blah blah this
is the demographic we're aim right this
is all these things that it seems that
other companies think about later
I suppose other Studios
probably don't go down the road because
they have people to do all that kind of
stuff yeah
because they don't make their own TV
shows obviously no we don't have that
that kind of uh
um
they don't have those people in the
business yeah it's almost like they
don't think about the creative side as
much
as like maybe other creative people will
um which can be good and bad you know
just you saying all this you know the
prime example that comes to my mind
the Lord of the Rings rings of power the
two creators are Patrick McKay and John
D Payne and try to find a credit prior
to Lord of the Rings I mean I think they
have a couple but nothing big and
nothing to deservedly get them Lord of
the Rings especially the first Lord of
the Rings television show but if they
made a good pitch if they were able to
convince somebody I mean that's what
they said Amazon said they had a really
good pitch so maybe they came in there
with the budget okay this is what we
need to buy Lord of the Rings yada yada
ABCD whatever it may be uh
and part of me likes that a lot because
it allows your earrings of power
no that's that's the thing it's I'm not
the biggest man in rings in power I
didn't hate it but it's not my biggest I
didn't love it by any means
but it did let two new creators try
their hand at something that they never
would have gotten otherwise
a lot of the mistakes that were made
with rings of power though was because
maybe they weren't experienced enough
and on the other hand yeah the second
series will be a lot better because
they've already come out and said we've
learned a lot from the first series and
I'm like well maybe if you'd have done
something else first and you'd have
learned those lessons from that and then
spend a billion of Amazon's dollars on a
on a TV show that people really care
about
but all of a sudden this is basically
maybe where they swung for the fences
definitely but this is where I think I
was going with this really is that that
because Amazon did all of a sudden
things like the rings of power decision
all I've seen seems to make more sense
because
that's how Amazon do it and they
literally do it on a really like a
business
method
um and they think about profitability
and all these sort of things really
early whereas other companies don't but
the other thing is it kind of makes
sense but this whole Stargate process
now I feel like makes more sense because
it it feels like
when they put it when in my business at
the moment I work for a council but when
they put things out for tender there's
loads of laws and things they have to
follow but they go through this really
like strict process and they stick to it
like crazy
um and it feels like Amazon is sort of
doing that they're going through a
process
and if it doesn't reach that bit easily
they're just going to go well
we'll just go to the next stage of the
process and they just
um but I suppose a good respect is
they're not putting all their eggs in
one basket and if it doesn't work out
with Hawk ospi and Mark Fergus for
whatever reason
um they'll just switch
so maybe it's not a bad thing but it I
don't know what you guys feel it feels
like a bad thing to me I don't
it doesn't it doesn't feel like the
creativity comes it feels like the way
they handle it is more as though it's
more like an investment on their part
like they're they're looking to invest
in something which is so they're trying
to make sure that what they're investing
in is going to work and this whole
process that they're going through if
they decide to pull out at the last
minutes because they can't see a return
on the investment
hmm yeah
and I think like I don't think they
think of things just creatively either
they seem to think of things
like I said I can't get away from this
they think of things from a business
point of view and it's they don't come
at it from a creative point of view it
feels to me like
somebody mg it's not MGM actually I
don't think so I don't think people like
Michael Wright think this way I think
Michael Wright the head of scripted
material at MGM has always been a big
fan of Stargate and would love that type
of project and he's been a coordinated
like insiders like Jenny stiven has been
fighting for it
um
then somebody so he thinks things think
from a creative point of view then
Amazon come in just as like bankers
it feels like and it's like well we're
just going to give you this money but we
like like Matt says but we want to make
sure we're not gonna
lose it you know what I mean so it's
like
they didn't do that with the expanse
though the reason the expanse got picked
up by Amazon because it was Jeffrey
Bezos like favorite shirt
like he loved the show and then decided
uh well you're going to cancel it I'll
just buy it and we'll carry it on there
are people who love Stargate as much as
he loves the expanse that's what that's
what he should realize
within his own business as well yeah I
mean I know Jeff Bezos has stepped back
a lot from
Prime which is mainly why the expanse
hasn't got another series because
they've maybe they are looking anymore
from a bean counter point of view
because that show however brilliant it
was and however much we love it never
made money
um
it's one of those shows that people
obsess over that love it but hasn't got
a wider audience
but um but a lot of times you know
streaming services now a lot of TV shows
used to make the money on syndication
but they don't do that if you just stick
it on one one streaming platform it's
re-watches now that are the equivalent
to that yeah before it used to be um I
mean how well a show does initially is
still massively important
and so like how things Premiere this is
what I'm told anyway
um so how it shows premiere and what
hours they get in the first thing
because it's all done by watch hours now
instead of views
um but it's they look like instead of
syndication where it's like companies
are coming to go oh I'd love to buy
Stargate and we'd love to show that on
our stream please what they look at now
is how many people watch that twice or
three times
and they love shows like that which is I
think it's another reason why I'm kind
of surprised they're not doing anything
with the expanse
I suppose they didn't just carry on
because people we will re-watch that
show
yeah but and there's a lot more storage
to be told as well yeah where this where
this series ends you know where the the
story has ended like
in original media in the books
the original nine books you've still got
those three years left but then there's
loads of books that surround it and
loads of spin-off novellas and things
and and there's all sorts of material
um but I'd say if you go back and look
at my previous video it looks like there
might still be
so now my title says the expanse to
Apple but my video actually very clearly
says that that's not really what is
maybe happening we don't know if it's
going to be the expanse or not but the
people that created the expanse Ty Frank
Shankar all these people are looking
like they're putting a production
company together and my sources are
telling me that they are talking to
Apple a lot
and that Apple would love them to
produce a TV show for them
if that could be something expanse
that'd be great but that really depends
on Alcon and Amazon whether they'll let
them but Amazon don't want it and Alcon
are about to get the rights back so it
could still be a thing that's one of the
things the main reason for this video
really today was I wanted to talk about
a lot of projects that we've had rumors
and a lot of movies guys for 2023 and
things that we're looking forward to
and I just want to give you you know I
want to get your ideas on what and
people in the comments as well what they
think
because there's a lot of projects that
we thought six months ago were like
nailed on to be made and now not so much
so
the expanse to begin with
Amazon seriously thought about doing a
Trilogy of movies they seriously thought
about continuing the series but on a
lesser budget they seriously considered
doing
um some
um series that would fill the gap of the
30 years between book six and seven all
of those things have just been put on
the Shelf because of money basically
but there's craploads of other projects
so I got a list so I just love you you
guys to give me really thumbs up or a
thumbs down on whether you want these
projects to happen and whether you what
How likely do you think it's going to
happen
first of all the new remote
is a series that again I wish stormy was
here because he would love it
and basically Punk sci-fi
um Warner Brothers are making it
they didn't want an HBO Max apparently
and
um but Apple TV apparently come in and
apparently very interested in making it
do you think that's a match made in
heaven I should say that Warner Brothers
and apple do have a good worker
relationship already they're doing the
um Speed Racer series for them this year
as well
okay okay
sorry
does that work
I'm thumbs up on this one for stormy I
can only give it a thumbs down because I
don't know anything about the the new
romancer you mentioned it before we
started here
yeah imagine Johnny
Johnny
that kind of reads me imagine that but
unlike acid
yeah it's it's a very ultraviolet very
thing yeah so I think that'd be cool and
I think yeah
cyberpunk sci-fi kind of like okay yes
that kind of thing this book actually
started that whole genre really in lots
of ways so I mean I think that's gonna
be I think Apple TV is the perfect place
that does sound kind of cool so I'll
give it a thumbs up
uh Battlestar Galactica movie and TV
series again six months ago looked
absolutely nailed on to be going to
pre-production it's stuck in development
um and it's confusing as [ __ ] I'll just
tell you this really quickly right so
one of the creators of the TV series
came out and said we're going to do
Battlestar Galactica
the TV series exists in the same
universe as the Ronald D Moore
Battlestar Galactica
and so does the film but in the same
sentence but the film is a hard reboot
so what are they doing the movie first
how are you booting it and then just
having a series or a lot of [ __ ] clue
well nothing's just the only way that
makes sense it doesn't make sense at all
in all honesty
um but I honestly think both of these
projects are probably dead I think the
TV series is good to Peacock if I
remember off top of my head
um and obviously the movie would have
seen release but it's just
it's just stupid I just I don't
understand it but it's it's stuck but
you guys bothered about it Babylon I'm
sorry
Galactica uh a reboot anyway
yes it already was a reboot
back in like the 10 10 15 year whenever
it was on 10 years
it was a was a
it's kind of a hard reboot but then they
brought stuff in from the original
series like you know some of the cylons
and the you know so he did it very
cleverly to be there
he left just enough in that the fans in
the original series didn't go ape [ __ ]
Harris well I've never actually seen it
I mean I've seen the movie I've never
seen the TV show or anything I know but
I'm a huge fan of Katie Sackhoff so at
best I can give it a halfway thumbs up
because I want Katie sack off in Star
Wars right now sorry
um
watch the miniseries they did it's
genuinely brilliant the series sort of
meander towardsian who sort of written
um but the mini series was genuinely
phenomenal and how many series can a
pretty six foot blonde girl kill a baby
and you're there like going what the
[ __ ] just happened
that's the first five minutes of the
series mate honestly it's fantastic
anything everything I'm in
fantastic okay then the Babylon 5 reboot
I was told a couple of months ago it was
completely dead not a [ __ ] chance
I'm now being told actually now the dust
has settled at HBO and at Disney he's
gone
he's left us he'll be back now the dust
is settled at Warner Brothers it might
actually be back on again
so
Babylon 5 reboot
area
oh you just disappeared and you think it
can come back don't you you're just like
there we go
Babylon 5 reboot I'd give a thumbs up
because I've never seen it
and that's why I gave it a sideways I've
never seen it but from what you and
stormy told about or what you and stormy
told me about it that one time we were
all streaming was
interesting really interesting but
I I don't see a reboot necessarily going
well
it's gonna be a hard boots
um boost on the ground hard reboot as
well so it'll be like the deals and
fears never happened
okay those are not very popular nowadays
so let's see how that works but the
original Creator James is actually still
show running still writing so from a bad
point of view I don't think that's ever
I I can't tell you many times that's
ever been done before
so it doesn't work let's see because
he's the same guy that you said wanted
to do it but wanted to not reboot it and
do it on the CW right
it was always going to be a hard reboot
so he always went harder but he wanted
to do it on the CW but it's one of those
delicate problems in Warner Brothers
want it for HPI Max
mm-hmm and they would love to play HBO
and they think it makes more sense on
HBO which I think it does
but from a contractual point of view CW
have first dibs
so even though Warner Brother Own It JMS
doesn't own any of the rights to Babylon
5 at all he's the Creator but he doesn't
own the rights
um Warner Brothers do but
the CW were the original Network and
they own some of the distribution rights
so they have got first dibs but then CW
was sport by Next Star
and everything that next door I've been
talking about for six months is that
they will not want to do more
that they're moving away from The Flash
and all these sort of shows and they
want to do more realistic like um
I should [ __ ] think I don't I hate it
love Island and crap like that it's
reality reality
Supernatural the reality is even
yeah so that's right if you think about
it from business
craploads of people watching it's really
easy to make
it's trash
yeah when you mentioned the CW uh doing
um
Babylon five that's what you're talking
about isn't it
yes yeah
you mentioned this Babylon five it was
whatever it was you called before you
mentioned them doing it I would I
wouldn't want them touching anything
because like so
my experience with the CW
I jumped I watched Smallville back in
the day I watched Arrow I watched The
Flash
um and those three shows are really good
and then they had then they started
making more shows in the same universe
and they kept adding on to the universe
but they they went too big too quickly
on every single one of them and now they
all suck including the flash which is my
favorite superhero
they're gonna do exactly the same thing
but anything they touch because every
single one of their shows has suffered
from the exact same thing they're gonna
be too big too early and it just Fizzles
out and it's never as good
I just there's bad reboot and then
there's a CW for me they're kind of on
the same page
yeah
The Flash is coming back next month
for the final season and I'm gonna watch
it because I love it but
I'm not I've not got high hopes for it
at all I played
all right well next on the list is one
that you guys won't care about or and
you're too young to have watched anyway
but there's an Airwolf reboot apparently
in early development and that's still a
possibility
I re-watched but yeah wolf recently it's
very very Camp
um all the way through watching
I'm not sure that man has a girlfriend
but anyway it's it's just a very very
strange show from that it's not as bad
as there's a series called Street uh no
uh Street Hawk
I don't know what's wrong with the
series in the 80s
they keep going on about an Airwolf
reboot though I just think bollocks to
an air ball for hebrewed I want an
A-Team reboot I want a proper TV series
of the A-Team I would watch that I would
watch a an 18 reboot 100
see I love an A-Team reboot but How
Could An A-Team reboot
I just how could they uh could they be
successful right now I I want to say yes
but like even people people joke about
The Expendables all the time and yeah
the third one's jokable but then there's
their first two are jokable too but
they're legit like adrenaline fun where
Airwolf could be adrenaline fun but it
could can't be quick yeah well they're
making another Expendables so this year
Expendables 4
. I love The Expendables I love it I
love the tongue and cheek I don't think
we needed four of them but I really did
enjoy the first one I thought it was
great
um
yeah but I I just think in 18 reboot is
just it's just so on the course they
tried it with the movie it didn't work
for the philosopher actually I don't I
didn't hate the movie I thought it was
okay but I think in the political
climate we're in right now but I want to
see it on HBO Max and you know when
those bullets flying everywhere and no
one gets even slightly scratched I want
people
grenades and people have just body parts
falling all over the place and like
they've locked them in the shed and they
built a tank and they come at the tank
and they just run some poor Suds head
over it's like Saving Private Ryan but
TV oh God yeah even more violent just
RoboCop level violence then oh yeah just
exactly yeah
that would be awesome
um
[ __ ] off
um
next question is Mr T
that's great David great comment
yeah
oh I didn't I didn't put it properly
there we go yeah get Chris Johnson Mr T
indeed I'd put it before yes that'd be
great
um next on the list Forbidden Planet
this is again a something I talked about
ages ago the MGM own
um and they apparently Amazon which is
one of the top five projects they
desperately wanted to do it was one of
the biggest sci-fi it still gets in like
the top 10 vote for like the the most
interesting Sci-Fi movies in history
um Leslie I want to say Leslie Nielsen
but I always get his name wrong thank
you and he's probably his only serious
role ever
um the robot from it became iconic the
robot in that movie took up nearly half
of the budget of the film building the
robot which is just just that just
cracked me up
um apparently now I heard about this
ages ago and they they really want to do
it I've recently heard that actually J
Michael susinski from Babylon 5
um Fame actually wrote a script in
collaboration with James Cameron and
that is currently sitting with MGM
so
that is something I would I would do to
have more solid information on this year
if we get anything in 2023 I want that
um and I do want to return a Robbie the
robot it'd be cool uh James Cameron said
he has a few other things that he has
worked on over the last 13 years of
course he's done a lot of Avatar but he
said he has a couple other things
well so I'm going to be talking about
this a lot because we do not want that
to get stuck in hell we want that we
want that made because that'd be awesome
it's a good story as well first ever
movie to actually be completely set off
Earth none of the plot of the movies on
Earth First first movie in history
um
next on the list Terminator reboot
sorry
James Cameron yeah again he's in
conversations about it I I don't know
how much he'll be involved but he's
obviously involved in at least some of
the conversations because he talked
about it and it would be a hard reboot
um
does that interest us I've I've got
kind of high hopes for that
being that it's a hard reboot now the
reason I think people don't
have high hopes for Terminator nowadays
as they did back back when it first come
out is because of how many iterations
they had and still kept Arnold
Schwarzenegger yes he is the original
Terminator but
he's an old man and he's just overusing
him
yeah it's so many more interesting
stories you could do with
um Skynet they don't always they don't
all have to look like um Arnold
Schwarzenegger or you know Summer Glau
um that series was really getting good
great it was really getting into its
stride when they canceled it I even
didn't hate the guy from 90210 that was
in it he was pretty good in it
um it was getting good man and the cut
I'm like
stupid shots I think that did well
because it had it didn't really have
anything to do with the original films
like none of the original cast for it
now there was no John Connor there was
no
um
Sarah O'Connor there was all original
characters and what Summer Glau
determined what was she called was she
no I don't know Terminator wasn't she I
don't know yeah
but it was original and that's that's
what I hope if they reboot uh so many
again they just make something original
not holding on to the you know the past
just I don't I just make a new story
there's so much you can do with Skynet
and and the war and things like that
they tried didn't they they had we had
the
Batman in a Terminator movie and I'll
just be trying to remember what it was
called but I can't get dark fate or
Genesis out in my head there's been so
many that one was Genesis right is it
Genesis I was thinking about it there's
one other one right there that I I can't
remember off the top of my head
um it was a load of rubbish anyway
um
and I think Genesis was Genesis the one
where
he somehow was able to age Salvage sorry
yeah Genesis was the one Arnold
Schwarzenegger was in there's only been
one somebody get in the comments please
tell us which was the one that didn't
have any in at all salvation Salvation
excellent so salvation was terrible
um it was a Terminator didn't know he
was a Terminator which was the only
clever bit in it actually I think
um but it's not a good movie I think
that's why they panicked and brought
Arnie back
oh no Arnie wasn't it I'm lying he
wasn't it yeah barely barely barely
barely it was the CJ wasn't it so even
in that they chickened out and put on in
it yeah well I think if they if they're
gonna do a hard reboot just just cut cut
all that out just just just accept the
fact that you're doing a hard reboot
can't someone like really good
because there are plenty of people who
could probably take on that mantle and
just do something good
is there any point that okay I was about
to say can I devil's advocate for a
second why why do Terminator at all
honestly I I mean I I don't know if you
all have seen Megan or not which just
came out in theaters the little creepy
AI doll
yeah yeah I haven't seen it yet but I
know what you mean I will I'll go see it
tomorrow probably but I won't give away
anything but just AI
Skynet
kind of go hand in hand in today's kind
of world everything that we're I mean
Chad GPT is a thing we're talking about
Elon Musk all the time all these little
different AI things happening
they're pretty prevalent does it have to
be Terminator talking about it because I
really don't think Arnold was the
problem for anything besides probably
dark fate dark fate yeah I'm with James
Cameron bringing back bringing back
another geriatric to do a bunch of stuff
he's not a geriatric but James Cameron's
words
that that was that was pushing it all
the others Arne had such a small part
and not even pivotal Parts they were
just the action that was it it was for
the action scenes it was never actually
pivotal to the plot so
I don't think he was the issue I I think
them just trying to to keep going I I
don't know what the issue is honestly
because like you said Matt they have so
many good things to draw from but
there's so many different places to do
that with now
I mean Genesis
uh so it's supposed to be good if
they kind of do a new Fresh take on it
if they were to do it
a Robocop could be AI now you know like
there's so many other things
I don't know there could be different
stories you could tell with the same
core characters but different motives
different intentions
if angles you could look from
I don't know
I guess I'm playing Devil's Advocate a
little bit here as well because I mean I
have no stocking in either of these
films so yeah no we're just asking the
question after the world but uh
reminisce not not I can't say that name
I'm very sorry I I tried uh Matrix
series might have potential and that I
mean honestly that's kind of the same
thing why not do another Matrix instead
of Terminator for AI I just I feel like
there's so many different AI things that
we could do and are the more we learn
about the technology itself and it's
implemented in all of our daily lives is
Just Your Average Joe's what what else
is going to come out with it you know
it's to me
with termite that's the argument that
it's been done to death
like yeah she's been done to death
and maybe it's just is it just a name at
this point yeah exactly right the
Firefly reboot right so Firefly if
you're a Sci-Fi fan and you don't like
the Sci-Fi I will come around your house
and kick you in the in the gentleman
area because it's it's it's everybody
loves Firefly it's my point it's one of
the great shows and you know people are
so disappointed and got canceled
um
they're talking about wanting to reboot
that but if they did
unless they can unless it's a
continuation it's just the name isn't it
it's just that just it's just a TV show
called Firefly
Terminator for me it would just be a
movie called Terminator with some robots
in they've told the story haven't they
didn't yeah they can't continue it it
would have to be a hard reboot and when
it's a hard reboot what's the freaking
point it must have just knocked do
something else
that's where I'm at
it's just it's just a title basically
that's all they're doing it's just a
title
at this point I think I I definitely see
that from from that point of view
however I do like Terminator and I would
like to see another film I just want to
see what they're going to do with it
yeah I love Terminator it's just I I
feel like if they announce something
else my first reaction will be
here we go yeah you know well like
Ghostbusters then Ghostbusters they do
Ghostbusters of boobs complete hard
reboot I mean you can we can go into the
woke agenda and how they how the the
creators got annoyed that some idiots in
the newspaper said women called the
Ghostbusters and they went yes they can
and they forgot to actually make a good
film we can get into that album all day
but at the end of the day it was a hard
reboot and everyone hated it they come
back with afterlife
and all they had to do was inject a
little bit of
the original casting and thing but they
did a continuation of the story and it
was phenomenal and we're going to be
getting a second one
so that's the one with the kids wasn't
it afterlife yeah so there are a lot of
ways you could do a Terminator movie
without doing a hard reboot but I just
think if they're doing a hard reboot
it's just it's just that that's not
understand the point I don't get it but
hey let's see let's see what they do
right next on the list
Harry Potter TV series we'll skip over
this one but I'd like to hear I I would
absolutely love to see a Harry Potter TV
series
well I don't like JK Rowling she can go
jump in the bin for like a as long as
she's not writing it I'm going to be
watching it
see I don't mind JK Rowling at all we
only have it because she's as brilliant
as a writer as she is you know
yes there's some stuff going on nowadays
but if she's got a team behind her
obviously don't let her write it all
herself we saw what happened with
Fantastic Beasts but I a team behind her
it might be a good thing
I I forgot what channel I think it was
the John campio show or something like
that I was watching this past week they
had a discussion about this and
because there's rumors I guess that
zazlov is going to just hard reboot all
Harry Potter which please know there is
there is that room and it makes no sense
to me I've heard that I was actually
told that this seems to have come from a
YouTuber who has apparently got he's got
a bit of um history of actually being
right so I don't I'm not going to slag
off any YouTuber that that you know if
they've got decent sources whatever but
um it makes no sense to me because those
films they're not that old and they are
iconic
I was going to say they
it feels like they've only just ended I
mean I know I've been nearly a decade
over a decade now probably it's been it
doesn't feel like like I could watch
them now and it feels new like yeah
enough you know what I mean so if you
have rebooted it now I mean in in like
30 years 40 years maybe
but not now
if I was going to hard to reboot Harry
Potter now and redo the original books I
would do a streaming series
and you would do it where you've got 10
12 15 hours of content put book and you
can actually tell a lot of the story
that they can't tell in a two-hour movie
that I do that and people would go
freaking crazy for it all the credits I
mean all the stuff they cut up the stuff
they cut out that they couldn't finish
the film you yeah yeah
the TV series apparently that they look
at is a Hogwarts TV season a TV series
um at the moment that's what's that's
the rumor I've had that this is
based on based on that because I watched
your video on it I'm wondering if that's
going to tie into Hogwarts Legacy you
know the film uh the the game Sorry
whatever it's going to be it's part of
the thing and apparently but a lot well
then I want to tell me about the Harry
Potter movies being
um really hard reboot
um he actually said that the Legacy to
do with that as well they want to see
how Legacy does and if it does they want
to try and figure snap time the other
way if we're doing a soft reboot of
Harry Potter is having new actors but
doing
Harry Potter becoming an aura people
would go crazy for that as well I don't
know why they ever did the magical
beasts
I I never I had never understood why
they'd never did a sequel they did it
because all the none of the actors
wanted to come back at that point Alan
Rickman I guess hadn't passed away yet
or no maybe he had because it was pretty
quickly after that last Deathly Hallows
film but I I think I really think it was
because all the actors didn't come back
if I remember correctly or they didn't
want to come back they were so young
they wanted new things in their careers
rightfully so but now that they're all
30
bring them back for the aura we I would
be very angry if they recast Daniel
Radcliffe I could see all of them coming
back even down I don't think Daniel
Radcliffe go back to Harry Potter they
would be expensive I know he said
repeatedly in thingies he's worked very
hard to get away from Harry Potter he
doesn't want to go back well the cursed
child is the one they keep saying about
would you make the cursed child into a
movie
and he repeatedly says that have you
still said that after that really good
uh last time reunion from last year last
interview I saw he was talking about
that he was very respectful about it it
wasn't like I'm not doing that [ __ ] he
was he wasn't like that it was just like
I've worked really hard to move away
from Harry Potter and I'd love to see
someone else do it but I just don't want
it and you've got to remember as well
the hardship he went through in his
early in his late teens early 20s with
alcohol and all this sort of thing
I wonder if
there's some emotional scars there that
maybe he doesn't want to revisit perhaps
yeah
um maybe but you know you think some of
the projects He took on to get himself
away but by the way guys if you haven't
watched bimbo watch it it's freaking
brilliant it's so good
um he is phenomenal in it as well once
you get past once you stop listening to
his American accent he's brilliant
have you seen Swiss army man
no oh he plays a flatulent corpse
I will have to watch that as well which
is fantastic for me I think the
Fantastic Beasts
may get one more movie and then it's
dead there's no way it's getting all
five I can't see it I'm I'd be I
wouldn't be surprised if it doesn't go
forth
um I've not seen the last one yeah
[Music]
but I mean we'll see what happens but I
think a TV series I just don't want to
do a prequel TV series I'd like them to
do something that moves into where we're
at and then
I'm So Gone
no no keep going finish that sentence
well let's go say respect the original
Source material and don't do what
Fantastic Beasts did and weirdly put Pig
in Dumbledore in a in a beautiful
three-piece
suit with a [ __ ] when did that man go
from wearing suits from Savile Row to
picking wearing dresses
why did that happen that's what happens
when you grow a really long white beard
please get him to wear the dress when
he's a Hogwarts okay wear the suit when
he's out and about and you know doesn't
want people looking at him but that's
something don't change the character
freaking completely
um
Canadians
with with all that
I if if they continued Harry Potter it'd
be cool if she maybe wrote some more
books and then they did that that might
be one thing but like we were just
talking about with Hogwarts Legacy and I
mean if you want to expand the thought
even more
how many just with Fantastic Beasts I
guess if you did see the latest one
there are like seven different nations
of wizards why don't we go hop over to I
mean we saw them in Hogwarts as well why
don't we go hang out with Ravenclaw
house or Hufflepuff house I'm team
Hufflepuff of course always but uh you
know what that means but
you'll get it uh but also think I mean I
know you don't like prequels but would
it really be a prequel I know Legacy is
happening in the 1800s middle of the
1800s what if we went back to the 1600s
1500s 1900s there's so much story to be
told with Harry Potter like the the
formation of Hogwarts or the full that's
great leaders godric gryffindors liver
and all of them people like the creation
of the like the Chamber of Secrets
you've got that entire story to tell but
like even more recently you've got the
entire story of like you could just have
a series based on Voldemort Tom Riddle
as a kid he grows up he he does like
crazy [ __ ] and he like
you know he does he does he screws he
screws over the Hagrid and we get to see
that on the TV series and like we get to
see all of the stuff that happens well I
like that idea because you know the the
guy that played young Tom Riddle in
Harry Potter he's like 28 34 somewhere
in that range I I would guesstimate but
he's one of the three main guys from
fear of The Walking Dead I only ever
watched the first season but I know he
continues for a little while he's the
guy with that long hair
toss them in it's a still a continuation
on every technicality he's turned into
gray finds with a noseless guy later on
you know I'm I'm not so excited about
the idea of a Tom Riddle
um prequel because we know enough about
where it happens and I don't think for
me uh I'm not that into that I love the
idea of like the Slytherin and the Raven
you know and actually you're seeing
those characters the original House
Hogwarts I love that idea because I
wouldn't even consider that almost a
prequel because that would be that's a
story we know virtually nothing about
yeah so they could create something you
have like the formation of the ministry
of magic you'd have
sure
around that time I'm pretty sure Muggles
and wizards lived together as well so
there wasn't the separation between
Muggles and wizards like that we have
recorded how that actually happened and
came to be
how much more dangerous Wizards were for
your average person walking around and
it would be a very large class
difference you know it would be a upper
class and lower class and there would be
no middle class there until I guess you
get your Hermione's and people like that
and it would be kind of finding or
fine-tuning all that world which would
be fun to watch yeah I think so
um the other option for me though is
just like say you recast Harry Potter
you do a series of an aura series and
always and the easy way doing that is if
you do it's a TV series and you Recon
Harry Potter people pattern Potter
Potter people won't freak out so much
because they do appreciate it's a TV
series so you're not going to get that
miracle if people would forgive that if
they do a movie without Daniel Radcliff
I think people would sort of go a bit
and I'm not so sure they'd have to get
the right guy in and there would be a
backlash but a TV series
Elijah Wood obviously Elijah was either
of those work absolutely weirdly
um but um
but creating a TV series with him as an
aura as well I would have thought that's
the easiest [ __ ] thing to write in
the world I can you can think it's
stories just spill out your head
wouldn't they I mean it's just like I'm
just having a wizard buff
yeah would you say a cannibal
you know how to slap the Shia LaBeouf's
son
let's not start with Shia LaBeouf
that's one thing as well by the way that
um you know we've got another
Transformers movie
um if that doesn't well if it doesn't do
amazingly well
you can expect a Transformers Hardware
reboot as well
that's it it wasn't a hard review with
the one as soon as they sat Shia LaBeouf
because it was supposed to be a
continuation and Optimus Prime
everything's still the same so well not
really a reboot now I thought this one
was though because this one is off of
Bumblebee right yeah and Bumblebee was a
reason no it's a prequel
ah but was it it said it said when
bumblebee first comes to Earth isn't it
Bumblebee it's supposed to be when that
bit when he's waiting
so he's waiting for Optimus Prime to
arrive so it's set before the original
when he's waiting on the scrap yard
oh my head Cannon's just it's just a car
we've got this before that but yeah but
anyway there would be a complete full
hard reboot if it doesn't do very well
and it's not going to so expect that in
future but um let's see uh next on my
list apparently the wiki who apparently
come to Richard Joy the wiki says
bumblebee was supposed to be a reboot
I'm pretty positive bumblebee was a
reboot I
yeah well I think
I think you've said before because it is
actually reference that he's waiting a
couple of times during the movie that he
was waiting for
um a message wasn't he and that is the
thing that message was he's waiting for
Optimus Prime to turn up but um but
anyway that was what I got from it I
don't think they directly referenced it
either way so I will I'm more than
willing to say you're both wrong
so I'm not going to get into
um
I mean you guys won't be interested in
this at all but after talking to um Sean
Ferrick yesterday from um Star Trek um
track yards please go and watch that
video it was freaking amazing I love
doing it
um I actually spoke to a proper
celebrity I joked them when he came up
because I was quite nervous I was like
oh [ __ ] I've never like spoken to
anybody 250 000 subscribers tracking um
track yards not trackyards Trek
culture's got
um
when you said it
trying to get in touch with the guy from
track yards yesterday so I'm trying to
get him on next but anyway
um so for technology so um I said to him
oh I'm quite nervous because he's so
weird it's like YouTube's talking back
at me and she couldn't stop laughing
about five minutes
but he's such a lovely guy really nice
guy but anyway when Picard series three
ends
we're expecting to get announced a new
Star Trek series and we're hoping for
something that is contemporary with the
Picard timeline and is it like this is a
[ __ ] based Series so I'm really hoping
in 2023
that's something we get to concrete on
that this is
Voyager kind of serious
not Voyager like like the Next
Generation
so avoyager even though it's a ship and
it's wandering around there was a plot
to it that it's lost in space basically
so it was like there's a story to Deep
Space Nine based on a space station with
the Wormhole there's this these this
this plot's very heavy set on and so you
you kind of knew what every episode was
going to be about voyagers every episode
was about them trying to get home sort
of thing
toxic Next Generation you didn't know
where they were going to go there's no
massive story arc it was just the ship
explore
someone keep it simple based on the
Enterprise I would genuinely
um I'll go I'll go Alex Kirsten All Is
Forgiven is a big kiss
I'll kiss you wherever you like and just
do me a show I actually want to watch
don't you just pull a face Harris you
know what I'm talking about oh and I was
reading hitchhiker's guy in the gala
Guide to the Galaxy comments
anything with your with them Jerry Ryan
awesome and yeah Richard that's the sort
of show I want to watch board the
Enterprise F crack on
um
they have tried to do A Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy Universe TV series
before that it was on BBC Two when we
were kids when I was a kid
um
I was I was not even a thought of
it would be nice if it was shut up Matt
um
I think they did do A Hitchhiker's Guide
to the suit but it was The Hitchhiker's
Guide though it was the TV
series so I know you mean a universe one
expands on that maybe yeah why not
um
as we talked about the expanse earlier
um we've got a ThunderCats movie
which would be a live action movie
Thundercats come on chatara
I know what Thundercats are I just think
it could be cool but didn't you see the
cats movie that came out
that's what I'm expecting I never
actually saw it but but
oh god
um and that's what it would look like if
they do it that's what it's going to
look like
they've already got a director of stuff
no no you can keep him we've took his
we've took his um passport back
um but yeah I used to love Thundercats
man we used to watch little cats when I
was kids and then we did and it would
then run the loose and that'd be the end
of it and then I would jump up and go
I'm panthro and punch my brother in the
face
and that's how we spent our Saturday
mornings my mom and dad coming up
I went you know that's I would I would
kill for a proper ThunderCats movie they
asked me how comfortable
are these similar things but for Power
Rangers
now that's something I want to see a
reboot of they did it not the 2017 [ __ ]
version no no no no no no
Brian Cranston was the only good thing
about no no it wasn't good it wasn't
good it was all right it was not good no
no no never watched it
no no
and Jason David Frank was in it as a
cameo so was Kimberly
um
sorry
it was her and Jeff from um Gladiators
do you remember Gladiators Matt
yeah if the older British people in our
audience will remember until they
remembered Jet and I saw her once she
was in the Town Center by me and she was
just like waving at me I swear to God
she's waving at me I was only about 12.
I love you too Judd she's she's so
pretty I'll send you a picture of a
later house you'll note I mean but
anyway
um
um but that would be cool uh the last
one on my list is the ham Weyland aliens
TV show which is going to be based
around the Weyland Corp at Weyland yet
to Annie or something
um Corporation
that's in early production at the moment
the producer Noah Simon kindberg is
producing
um he's also producing a million other
TV series
including um The Running Man a reboot of
the Running Man which we'll see
um it's in pre-production at the moment
Starlight and pre-production
um uh Logan's Run
which is um potentially going to get a
reboot and he is also supposed to be
producing the Battle Star Galactica
movie so he's a busy busy boy look at
this IMD you have to scroll down a lot
good he's working on at the moment
the alien show is showran or Show run
whatever the grammatical correct thing
there is for with uh Noah Holly correct
the guy that did Legion okay good good
anything to a holly I'm excited for yeah
slightly iffy yeah there's also an
aliens movie
supposedly come in but there's no
definite on that just yet the Wayland is
just thing but the Wayland will
apparently be Fox so that'll be on the
UK Disney plus which is excellent
um but it's going to be focused more on
the business practice we might get to
see more a bit more of like the building
the Androids and stuff and the AI stuff
rather than
let's see how many Xenomorphs actually
turn up but
so
um I said Romance the whole point of
this conversation was that none of those
have been announced they're all rumor
and well all in development almost all
of it's in early development except
Airwolf which as far as I know no
decisions been made everything else is
listed as early development
so that's the point was we want all of
these things to be
greenlit we want them to be actually go
from development to production in 2023
that's what I'm hoping for
um Logan's Run for example fingers
crossed
so that's where we're at how about you
guys sorry I've just took up an hour of
that and I promise you guys you'd be
allowed to
throw some things in but movies are
actually looking forward to 2023 stuff
that is actually being made and is
actually going to come out what we're
looking forward to movies are going to
be TV shows either
somebody's just gonna book Rogers sorry
I'll throw you quickly on that one I've
been trying to find out I can't find out
Smokehouse with um things supposed to be
making this it's supposed to have gone
in production it just hasn't happened so
it's another one of these that's just
stuck in development hell as far as I
can tell
um like uh Mark Wahlberg's first we're
doing the six billion dollar amount that
was announced ages ago and it's just
nothing's happened
so um I was told basically that about
one in eight shows that go to
development ever get made so we'll wait
and see
but anyway Harris movies you're looking
forward to you Cinema go I can't believe
I've actually got you talking here this
long without you going to the cinema
halfway through it's about to say
where should I start I I've got two
sides of uh bullet points ready for this
one interesting one okay well
interesting and recent up to date that
you can go sit in a theater right now in
was Megan Megan is legitimately a really
good family movie
it's legitimately a good horror movie
it's gonna say it's legitimately a
thriller movie but she's better than
Chucky in a lot of ways kind of similar
to like the new AI Chucky in a way but
she's she's different I I was
legitimately surprised I had high
expectations and then I saw that it was
PG-13
so I kind of lessened my expectations
and then my expectations got blown away
again so that was great uh so no Megan's
really good I I so that that's this
month I would say past that I'm excited
next month for Ant-Man three quantumania
just looks like a lot of problems
but it does look good I am excited by
that that's the one and like you said
Paul Rudd made sure it was uh a little
bit better for each film so and we just
talked about Ghostbusters afterlife give
us some Paul rudden I'm happy with that
you know
uh then there's cocaine bear
what Winfield looks pretty good and
Dungeons and Dragons looks pretty good
uh
but
[Music]
I don't know I I think besides that
mission impossible
maybe some uh
Oppenheimer that's another really good
one I'm just reading down this list
say what I think the uh that 65 with
Adam
driver yes
he's especially an astro this on an
alien planet from what I could tell and
there's a load of dinosaurs
um and that's a basic plot mechanism
that I'm like I'm on board that throw
some sharks in and I'm good Discovery
weeks it looks great yeah it does look
good
um I'm crap with that I'm a bit
concerned what you mentioned Dungeons
and Dragons I'm a bit concerned about
that I've seen a few of the trailers now
and I'm like
I'm not sure about that I think I think
that's going to disappoint
the the first trailer I watched I was
like oh this looks fun and then I kind
of thought about it and I wasn't all
excited about it but the next trailer I
guess I rewatched that trailer in the
next trailer and after watching the cast
talk about it a little bit like
Comic-Con and things like that they all
seem like they legitimately had a good
time making it and they had a good it
feels like they all loved every inch of
the process of making the movie which
that in itself excites me for it because
if everybody's having a good time
how can it be bad in a lot of ways there
are ways that's possible but it does
tend to bleed through on screen doesn't
it when yeah that's the thing that
they're saying about we mentioned
Firefly earlier that's one of the things
they always said about that was they
they just adored making the show and
they were all really close by the end of
it and I think it does tend to bleed
through and when actors aren't getting
on or when the environment isn't good
I think that bleeds through as well
sometimes doesn't necessarily mean it'll
be a good film but it should be fun yes
so and and like I said it's a movie I I
would love to work
it has to be fun
because again
so yes it's not fun what's the point
it's got to be a bit tongue-in-cheek
with nice tongue and cheek is the last
Dungeons and Dragons movie which which
again I loved which we talked about this
couple of weeks ago Jeremy Irons Camp
can help it over acting like freaking
crazy it was marvelous
um but it was a bit too tongue-in-cheek
to have a wider audience so yeah it's
got to have fun with itself but it can't
go too far I I hope they set up a sequel
and Jeremy Irons just kind of pops up in
the back at some point and then just
over someone
and that dude's got the snakes going in
his ear and Jamie I'm just on his
shoulders look like he's bumping him but
um genuinely uh go and watch it it's
it's just
beyond belief
um that was one of those times the first
time I ever realized when a production
company is not very confident in the
movie they will be like nine production
companies you know like in association
with in association with an associate
and that was the first time I ever
realized this because I think they knew
this film was going to be [ __ ] so they
spread the risk out as much as humanly
possible
um
the only other interesting Factor about
the original Dungeons and Dragons movie
was the side cfgi company was a new
company and they were they just wanted
to
um do it to show what they could do and
the CGI is actually really good in
Dungeons and Dragons they did it
completely for free they didn't charge
at all and they took some of the back
end off which there wasn't any because
the film bombed
um but but yeah they didn't take any
charge they just did it as an exercise
to show what they could do wow that's
cool though that that's not an easy feat
to be working for free like that on
something like that okay
yeah exactly look at this [ __ ] film we
did brilliant pretty dragon's floor
but there's a big Dragon Battle of them
it's actually quite cool
they're going to their wives at the end
of the day and go how much did you make
from that how rich are we are we did it
for free you [ __ ] did it
don't worry it's gonna be a massive hit
how many people was watching agree
that was me I was like this is great
um oh it's a terrible film
um but but yeah it's just one of those
films that's so bad I loved it
my friend well I could keep naming off
movies there's there's a lot that are
just TBD for announcement dates so we'll
leave those there but Series wise I'm
I'm not excited for it but I'm intrigued
by The Witcher season three just because
I know it's going to be Henry Swan Song
and I I want to know if it's going to be
good because he knew it was going to be
or if it's going to be awful and he was
like all right this is my this is I'm
bowing out I'm out because it could be
either way uh yeah besides that
all the Star Wars shows are gonna be
great this year but I'm really pumped
for invincible season two I don't know
if y'all watch that on Amazon Prime but
that's probably Amazon's my favorite
show that's coming on Amazon so far I
would love it
uh the uh we all think about the same
thing of the boys spin-off s
it's uh it's it's similar in tone a lot
but it's the same guy that wrote The
Walking Dead comics he wrote that comic
Coast is the main superheroes to go the
mustache and exit yeah it's very it
feels like the boys doesn't it but yeah
I did enjoy being small so I saw that
when it first came out this was a little
while ago
[Music]
um I should have thrown in the He-man
live action supposed to be made this
year but that's could have gone quiet
and if they don't make a he-man live
action movie I'm gonna go and find out
who's responsible I'll kick them in the
nuts as well I that's my youth man I
want a He-Man movie
whenever you say live action here man is
that like compare the markets
amazing
oh man the only thing I can see is like
Dolph Lundgren walking around in some
leather underwear that sounds like the
live-action hey man
did you did you ever watch Keith Lemon
he done a come time with me
and he dressed up as he man and that
scale that's all coming because I think
he already invited him because he knew
he didn't start some drama
all right so I know you've got no
freaking clue what we're talking about
a very funny guy over here
um I I will we'll call it an evening
because we've just gone past an hour but
or a morning for Young Harris
um but yeah I just I'd love to see I
just think in the next couple of months
we could get a few projects get a bit
more concrete information on like
Stargate
um that's what really inspired me to
start having to think about this there's
so many really good projects as I said
six months ago we really thought we're
nailed on and now not so much
um
doctor who's coming out in the 60th
anniversary in November yeah yeah yeah I
heard David Evan's gonna be in it mate
oh really
travel in time
they'll shout Alonzi at some point he
definitely does that's in the trailer
because of the Disney plus deal they're
also going to be doing spin-offs
and are really really hope they do
another sort of Torchwood um show
because I [ __ ] love Torchwood canine
they need to do canine K9 would be good
yeah that looks stupid it's a
I can't do it again but they're going
thanks to Disney plus deal my only
concern about Doctor Who is that their
budget is going through the roof so they
um I was told it's going to be like
anything up to five times what the
current budget is and I believe they get
about two million dollars an episode on
average
um I think I've top head so in that case
if they're getting four or five times
they pick an eight to eight to ten
million dollars an episode for Doctor
Who that puts it in line with budgets
like Dr um Star Trek
or you know a Netflix series The Witcher
even uh it's a little bit less than the
witching it's a little bit more than
that but um that's a proper money
is it gonna be Doctor Who anymore
as long as the the story is still Doctor
Who ish
just looking different doesn't change
doesn't change much I mean they they
they gave it more of a budget in the um
which career in the in the previous
Incarnation yeah
a much a much bigger budget for visuals
but the story was [ __ ] so
it looked good but it just had no
substance but now Russell T Davis is
back
and he's a fantastic writer and he's
going to bring in loads more fantastic
writers
I have High Hopes the budget is only
just going to make it like it's going to
be like the icing on the cake like it's
going to be a really good cake but he's
that's gonna be the Atlanta little
sprinkle of like oh yes
I was just focusing on those things that
they just don't like need to spend it
you know it's like we've got tell them
in the pound spin let's just like go
crazy on the special effects and we'll
do all this thing and I think they'll
there it's gonna look very American
which they did during the Matt Smith era
and the end of the David Tennant era
they tried to make it more approachable
for American audience and I would argue
that it worked to be honest so
um but I just think of other TV series
remember when um red dwarf they
reformatted that and spent a bit more
money on it to make it because it was
actually people were watching it on BBC
America
and through getting watched in America
so they actually did this weird thing
where they did um uh two seasons of 12
episodes which we never do in the UK
normally a show like that is six
episodes back then and so they did two
12 episode series so they could show it
in America as a 24 episode season
and it was crap it was really the death
of Red Dwarf it really was because it
lost
the the joy and it was it wasn't the
dwarf anymore it was trying to be an
American show and it just failed
horribly so let's let's just hope
they've got more sense
than to make it I I don't think there's
going to be any
um let's give that with Doctor Who
really because it's it is a
quintessentially British television show
and Americans watch it because of the
British like humor and the British
British like mandarins and
like they they they feel like they get
to know us a little bit I guess
well another example here is Downton
Abbey Downton Abbey started here as a
BBC One
um Sunday night show nobody expected to
watch in America they watched in America
the third season I believe they really
upped the budget and you wouldn't know
they just sort of did a bit more the
cinematography got a bit better and they
got a bit of bigger cast and they did a
few episodes where they actually went
off left their numbers so the budget
increased and they just made a bigger
show but you but they had enough sense
not to actually change the bbcness of it
if that makes sense
I don't think much will change in terms
for Doctor Who
um I think what they'll probably because
because it's going to be more like
production cost that they're going to be
investing in it's going to be more
practical effects so in the past Doctor
Who has always suffered because they've
only been able to afford maybe like two
or three dialect models so if it was a
really Dalek heavy episode they've only
actually physically got four model which
means they have to film that that model
multiple times maybe the pentagos means
they could have a little bit more they
could have a little bit more of a bit
more budget to make more to actually
fill out the room you know have better
pyrotechnics and all that stuff
hmm I don't think it will actually we we
probably won't notice it as much
um just as a viewer
if they do it well you won't notice when
things are good you tend to notice when
they they like worse you tend to notice
so if the CGI improves you probably
won't notice
yeah and it just be like oh it just
won't be as noticeable that it's bad and
sometimes the CGI and the special
effects is terrible so I think that was
always part of is charm wobbly sets bad
CGI
I was thinking about Matt Smith on the
motorbike driving up the side of The
Shard
that's really bad
um all right then guys well let's hope
um
that they can do something interesting
to be honest because I say I think 2023
is going to be an interesting year
one word of warning this is a Sci-Fi
channel we talk about fantasy stuff
occasionally but we're mainly a Sci-Fi
channel it does seem to me that we're
moving away from sci-fi and that a lot
of these projects we're talking about a
lot of the big projects we're talking
about that are coming up and have been
announced at the moment are more fantasy
swords and wizards and things we seem to
be heading back towards so let's
watch your Sci-Fi TV shows because you
know we need to convince people to keep
making them
um
rename myself to Fantasy track
we're gonna get weird people watching
them know me the the only good thing
about that is our logo could be Danny
Gandolf
well it should be anyway really if you
think about it would oh I'll have to
make a vector
I'm just your whole video and insisting
station character for the entire video
and the intro or just him with a staff
gun you shall not pass yeah that would
be great
you shall not pass
guys thank you so much for get coming on
and having a chat
um hopefully we'll be back next week
hopefully we'll be right next week with
stormy bear
which would be great I have no idea what
we're going to talk about so guys if you
want to get to the comments and tell us
what we should talk about we're always
willing to listen to you guys and then
completely ignore you and do what we
want anyway
um
we really appreciate your feedback we
are going to ignore you try and say that
with a bit more now we really do
appreciate your feedback
um we do
um I think we listen to uh I I think we
involved do not read the comments the
love of God you'll it'll just kill your
soul and I was like no I like reading
the comments because even though some of
them are complete trolls and they're
just out to
irritate me for no reason or us for no
reason and most of them are actually
fascinating and the amount of videos
I've created I read all the comments now
I didn't when I first joined
I started reading the comments and I was
like I do not want to read these
comments they're really annoying me
we had conversations about it but no I
really don't know
comments here on Twitter again
everywhere so
well we got we luckily we got like say
that Jenny Steven video I think did us
really well when she actually gone and
went no he's not talking [ __ ] they
actually do
they're talking a lot of sense and that
did us a lot of good because now I can
just hit people on the head of that as
soon as somebody goes you're talking
[ __ ] and let's go
well
am I there so um even though this one
guy it did message me the other day and
he was just like um and I shouldn't have
engaged with him I know I shouldn't have
engaged with him and I was so annoyed
with myself afterwards but he started
having to go with me saying um
and I said look go and watch the dial
the gate video when James Avenue knows
what she's talking about basically said
Sidetrack every two minutes for the
entire video and she's basically said
this this and this was right and we were
the first ones to say it
um I think you and this guy wasn't
you're just so excited she mentioned
your channel you didn't actually listen
to her I was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me at one point I asked her a
question about
um
other these click baiting channels and
she went basically she basically said
what side track isn't they know this
they got this right they're good and she
just like she really defended us really
brilliantly
um and you know I'm just thinking that
it gave us a bit of credibility anyway
because I can understand people that
assumed you were talking [ __ ] because
we've come from nowhere and I just
started telling you what bloody
executives are talking about to Amazon
like a couple of other people would like
go [ __ ] off
um
I did get a comment back from
um
this is Darren
off gateworld oh Garrett down yeah yeah
yeah and I did have to send him back and
I said about he says look we should be
we should be friends we should be a
community and we should work together
and yes I didn't trust you at first and
I'm sorry about that and then but then
and I know Jenny Steven
um sort of confirmed some of your things
you've said and I'm like some
and I did that so I've sent him a slight
slightly
forceful email back
just sort of saying that look uh we I I
would love it if we were friends but at
the moment I know some of the things
you've said about me so it's a little
bit difficult yeah apologized and even
in that video they still kept going on
about they still they did not say they
did not name our Channel Jenny was
whether they liked it or not but um
Jenny backs up with that so let's see
but anyway I saw a podcast video
yesterday and they said Sidetrack every
45 seconds and it was beautiful exactly
I've I've been talking to the podcast
guy yeah
I sent you they played very clearly on
one of their live shows been watching
Sidetrack because they accidentally
played it and you know the old intro
intro the the music plays and and he
stops it but I was like I know that
intro anyway because I spent hours
looking for that [ __ ] song they took
they then talked about some of the
things we've been talking about and
talked about they they skirted around
um that we because they've talked about
Jenny's diving and stuff and they'd
skirt it around us so I messaged him
after that and went what the [ __ ] and
actually I've been speaking to them and
they're they are really nice guys and
they've released a new video now that
they re-edited just so they could
reference us because they said look at
the end of the day
and then he tweeted as well a really
nice tweet just sort of saying look go
and have a look at Sidetrack there
they're the guys that are talking about
Stargate and we're the guys that seem to
be the front line of it and because at
the end of the day at the moment at
least when it comes to Stargate
um we are the we are getting everything
first
so
um
and other people are following us
so you're our Jack O'Neil and and the
three of us are uh who you're teal
indeed I'll take it
um actually I have to be honest Matt
should be teal
who's stormy
you'd be Daniel to Harrison
stormy would be Sam just because he's so
smart he actually gonna fix the bill
and he is sexy let's be honest oh that
Danny Gandalf you know I love that again
though but guys thank you so much for
attending again
um we're gonna call it everyone in the
comments
um again I've not been able to keep up
with it all because you've just put some
brilliant comments are some and Scoot by
um sorry I haven't put a few more up
today but I just can't read more I'm so
sorry I do try to keep up but um thank
you very very much we will see you next
week whatever the hell you want to talk
about just let us know say bye everybody
adios yo see you later